one winter morning a couple of years ago
I was riding to work in Johannesburg
South Africa and notice a haze hanging
over the city and make that drive on
most days so it was unusual that I
hadn't noticed this before Johannesburg
is known for his distinctive skyline
which I could barely see that morning it
didn't take long for me to realize that
was looking at an enormous cloud of air
pollution the contrast between the
scenic environment I knew and the smog
covered skyline stirred up something
within me I was appalled by the
possibility of the city of bright and
vivid sunsets being overrun by a dull
haze at that moment I felt an urge to do
something about it but I didn't know
what all I knew was I couldn't just
stand idly by the main challenge was I
didn't know much about environmental
science air quality management or
atmospheric chemistry I am a computer
engineer and I was pretty sure I
couldn't code my way out of this air
pollution problem was I to do anything
about this issue I was but is a citizen
in the following years I learned a very
important lesson a lesson we all need to
take to heart you were to work towards a
better future even if you're not an
expert in a particular domain your
outside expertise may hold the key to
solving big problems within that domain
sometimes the unique perspective you
have can result in unconventional
thinking that can move the needle but
you need to be bold enough to try that's
the only way they'll ever know what I
knew back then was that if I was even
going to try to make a difference I had
to get smart about air pollution first
and so I became a student again I did a
bit of basic research and soon learned
that air pollution
is the world's biggest environmental
health risk data from the World Health
Organization shows that almost 14
percent of all this worldwide in 2012
were attributable to household and
ambient air pollution with most
occurring in low and middle income
countries ambient air pollution alone
causes more deaths each year than
malaria and hiv/aids in Africa premature
deaths from unsafe sanitation or
childhood malnutrition pale in
comparison to deaths due to air
pollution and comes at a huge economic
cost over 400 billion u.s. dollars as a
2013 according to a study by the
Organisation for Economic Cooperation
and Development now in my work I explore
new frontiers for artificial
intelligence where the symbiotic
relationship between man and machine can
find a beneficial footing and help us to
make better decisions as I thought about
the air pollution problem it became
clear that we needed to find a way to
make better decisions about how we
manage air pollution and given the scale
of the problem it was necessary to do it
in a collaborative way so I decided I
better get to know some people working
within the field I started to speak to
officials from the city of Janis Berg
and other surrounding cities and I
engaged the local scientific community
and I also made a few cold calls the
process of engagements are embarked upon
helped me to develop a deeper
understanding of the problem it also
helped me to avoid the trap people in my
profession sometimes fall into when
trying to innovate where we are quick to
apply a technology before we firmly
grasped the problem at hand I began to
develop an idea about what I could do to
improve the situation I started by
simply asking myself how I could bring
together in some meaningful way my
skills in software engineering and
artificial intelligence and the
expertise of the people I'd reached out
to I wanted to create an online air
quality
tea management platform that will
uncover trends in pollution and project
into the future to determine what
outcomes can be expected I was
determined to see my idea translate into
a practical solution but I faced
uncertainty and had no guarantee of
success what I had was a very particular
set of engineering skills skills I'd
acquired over my career that we knew to
people we've been working on the air
pollution problem for so many years what
I've come to realize is that sometimes
just one fresh perspective one new skill
set can make the conditions right for
something remarkable to happen our
willpower and imagination are a guiding
light enabling us to chart new parts and
navigate through obstacles armed with a
firmer understanding of the air
pollution problem and having managed to
source over a decade's worth of data on
air pollutant levels and the
meteorological conditions for in and
around Johannesburg my colleagues from
South Africa and China and myself
created an air quality decision support
system that lives in the cloud
this software system analyzes historical
and real-time data to uncover the
spatial temporal trends in pollution we
then used new machine learning
technology to predict future levels of
pollution for several different
pollutants days in advance
this means that citizens can make better
decisions about their daily movements
and about where to settle their families
we can predict adverse pollution events
ahead of time identify heavy polluters
and they can be ordered by the relevant
authorities to scale back their
operations through assisted scenario
planning city planners can also make
better decisions about how to extend
infrastructure such as human settlements
or industrial zones we completed a pilot
of our technology that was run over a
period of a hundred and twenty days
covering all of South Africa our results
were confirmed when we demonstrated
tight correlation between the
forecasting data and the data we were
getting on the ground through our
leadership we have bought cutting-edge
world-leading assets that can perform
air quality forecasting at an
unprecedented resolution and accuracy
benefiting the city that I drove into
one winter morning not very long ago and
put to myself something is wrong here
I wonder what can be done so here is the
point what if I had not investigated the
problem of air pollution further what if
I had not shown some concern for the
state of the environment and just hope
that someone somewhere was taking care
of the matter what I have learned is
that when embarking on a challenging
endeavor that advances a course that we
firmly believe in it is important to
focus on the possibility of success and
consider the consequence of not acting
we should not get distracted by
resistance and opposition but this
should motivate us further so wherever
you are in the world the next time you
find that there is some natural
curiosity you have that is being piqued
and it's about something you care about
and here are some crazy or bold ideas
and perhaps it's outside the realm of
your expertise ask yourself this why not
why not just go ahead and tackle the
problem as best as you can in your own
way you may be pleasantly surprised
thank you
[Applause]